you know that what you say fanaa which
is this idea of annihilation or being
extinguished in God that's even though
that's considered like a high point of
the spiritual path the actual there's a
step after that like I mentioned earlier
which is Baka which is often translated
as subsisting in God and so the the this
this experience of of being nothing of
uniting with God is actually to some
degree a temporary experience because
then you return to multiplicity and you
continue experiencing this this this
fluctuating manifestation of God but now
you understand that it is God you can
see how it is God and in what way it is
not God and so on
um but yeah so so definitely there's
there's a continuing
uh
the journey continues so to say